this episode is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon this series could
not exist without the support of our
amazing patreon patrons so we want to
start this one out by saying a big thank
you to those of you who have chosen to
support us if you'd like to join our
community of patreon supporters you can
do so by going to patreon.com journey to
micro for just two dollars a month you
can support this Channel and get access
to our Patron only Discord for other
viewers of the channel discuss not only
our videos but also their own microscopy
on top of that you'll also get a monthly
hour-long video of some of our uncut
footage and if you want to bump up your
support to eight dollars a month you
will still get access to all that stuff
but also you'll get weekly high-res
wallpapers of your favorite microbes and
your name will be added to the list of
supporters that we show at the end of
every video if you'd like to check it
out you can sign up at patreon.com
journey to micro
[Music]
thank you
foreign
do microbes ever feel fear or concern or
trepidation while they can't of course
tell us they probably don't at least not
in the ways that we would understand but
we can tell that they definitely
experience stress
now that stress is not terribly similar
to what we experience when tax season
rolls around or a traffic jam makes you
late for an important meeting the
microbial world is mercifully free of
such troubles but at its core what
microbes experience is stress
nonetheless the recognition of and
response to less than ideal
circumstances
and when you think about it of course
the micro Cosmos can be a very stressful
place from shifts in food availability
to sudden temperature swings to changes
in PH that can begin picking apart a
micro molecule by molecule all in all
there's a lot going on that can get in
the way of microbes living their best
lives so maybe it is no surprise that
naturally stressed microbes are
everywhere
[Music]
like a bear going into hibernation
through a frigid winter this tardigrade
also known as a water bear has seemingly
given up trying to face the stresses of
the world instead it is lying Motionless
in a state of reduced metabolic activity
almost as if it is simply waiting for
all of its problems to disappear it has
formed a durable and protective cyst and
it will stay in there until more
favorable conditions arise and it can
stay insisted like this for months to be
woken up by a change in Seasons perhaps
microbes from all domains of life have
evolved similar abilities to outlast
those trying times and they do this by
entering extended periods of reduced
metabolic activity or dormancy because
while microbes can be found everywhere
you point your microscope that doesn't
mean they can Thrive just an anywhere
each species has its own preferences
when it comes to Habitat its own comfort
zone that is specific to its biology and
way of life Paula fire resiliates for
example prefer non-acidic habitats that
have plenty of dissolved oxygen if these
ciliates find themselves in a more
stressful acidic environment they too
form cysts and sit tight waiting for the
World to Change if they're lucky that
change might arrive in the form of heavy
rains that increase the pH of those
puddles and pools that their cysts lie
dormanten sensing a more hospitable
habitat they reawaken face the day and
go about their ciliate business
now cysts are not the only way members
of the microcosmos can enter the liminal
boundary between life and death though
these bacteria have found another way to
cope
the brighter Pockets at their tips are
the first stages of their last resort to
stress maybe it's a lack of nutrients in
the sample maybe the pH levels don't
suit them whatever it is that's left
them distressed their coping mechanism
is unfolding they're each building a
cellular bunker a Spore which we can see
forming here their DNA and essential
cellular Machinery will be almost
completely dehydrated and tightly packed
inside the spores thick envelope
eventually the Spore will abandon the
cell altogether jettisoning like an
escape pod as the mother cell undergoes
a self-destruct sequence in their Spore
form with their metabolism at minimum
possible levels they can last for
decades or even centuries protected from
the harshest of conditions biting their
time but until then they are part of the
ecosystems microbial seed bank the
repository of dormant microorganisms too
stressed out by local conditions to
fully live their lives but also just too
stubborn to die
seed banks are a big deal in the
microcosmos they allow species to enter
Cold Storage when times are tough in
that seed bank species have Tapped Out
of the stressful game of life or death
they found a temporary third option and
when they awaken whole microbial
ecosystems can simply pick back up where
they left off
you can wake up a seed bank yourself and
watch it happen at home all you need is
some food and of course a microscope if
you soak the vegetables and herbs
destined for your next meal and water
overnight and check the water under your
microscope the next day you are pretty
much guaranteed to spot some culpited
swimming around you have just enticed
them out of the seed bank by providing
them with a welcoming wet habitat you
triggered them to exist not to exist but
to exist culpited ciliates can be found
in soils around the world and they will
often hitch a ride on the surfaces of
your food now do not lose any sleep over
the idea that you are exposed to and
ingesting dormant microbes throughout
your day that is just part and parcel of
Life on this planet I promise like you
consume them just breathing it's just
one of many of the bridges between us
and the micro Cosmos insisted Copa dids
are not dangerous they're just sleepy
stowaways make taking the trip from the
soil to the surface of the tomato and
then into your mouth
James our master of microscopes often
tries a few different tricks to coax
stressed out microbes back into
existence and using different chemical
cues he can activate the dormant cysts
and spores of different organisms if he
wants to awaken the seed banks of
microbes that have a particular love of
sulfur for example he might add the yolk
of a cooked egg to the sample for others
the wake-up call comes in the form of
fertilizer which provides nitrogen and
phosphorus this stage that we're looking
down at right now can host an endless
combination of casts performing an
endless number of plays it all comes
down to Direction it seems wherever you
look in the microcosmos microbes
enduring stressful conditions can be
found suspended in a Twilight Zone
between life and death each species
Sitting Waiting holding out hope for
their own version of paradise to appear
foreign
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thanks again to
our amazing supporters over at
patreon.com journey to micro you'll be
seeing some of their names on the screen
pretty soon look there they are right
now like I said at the beginning of the
episode we could not do this show
without your support so we wanted to
thank each and every one of you who have
supported this channel over the last
almost four years that we have been
doing it I am so happy to have been able
to be a part of the creation of this
show and thank you to everybody who is
or ever has been or ever might be a
patron you can check it out at
patreon.com journey to micro thank you
so much if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
foreign
[Music]